[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
bruno retailleau bonjour bruno
retailleau banlieue bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nos sénateur de la
vendée président du groupe l'est
républicain ici au sénat on est ensemble
pendant un peu plus de vingt minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale
représentée par stéphane bern qui dirige
le bureau parisien de ouest france
bonjour stéphane bonjour organes et on
commence bien sûr à bruno retailleau par
cet article 24 qui n'en finit pas de
faire débat et notamment au parlement
alors ya eu il ya quelques jours cette
annonce de commissions indépendantes par
jean castex puis il ya eu en début de
semaine cette volonté des députés de la
majorité de réécrire complètement
l'article 24 c'est ce qu'ils ont dit
comment vous qualifiez vous ce qui s'est
passé ces derniers jours autour de cet
article amateurisme légèreté mépris du
parlement absurdistan on a tout eu et
évidemment en plus l'exécutif a vu sa
majorité sa propre majorité se dresser
contre contre lui c'est inédit
en réalité on avait deux problèmes on a
le problème de la rédaction de l'article
24 une rédaction totalement maladroite
ou il faut qualifier une intention ce
qui est très difficile on met un délit
dans le cadre d'ailleurs de la loi sur
la liberté de la presse donc on imagine
évidemment le comment dirais-je en tout
cas l'inquiétude est journaliste et donc
on a un article qui est à la fois
inopérant et un article très très mal
rédigé mais on a un autre problème
cirque à un mois près le gouvernement
nous propose au parlement de rédaction
différentes la rédaction dans le cadre
de cet article 24 sur la sécurité
globale et un autre article pour ce
qu'on appelle le texte qui devait être
le texte pour lutter contre le
séparatisme qui sera le texte pour
renforcer les principes républicains
là aussi où on voit que 1 on a une
réaction de monsieur darmana et l'autre
qui est sans doute une réaction de
monsieur dupont moretti
c'est à dire de la chancellerie donc à
un mois près le gouvernement propose au
parlement
quasiment deux rédactions différentes
mais finalement pour la même finalité
c'est pas du travail c'est de
l'amateurisme et je pense quand je
parlais de
légèreté c'est que il ya beaucoup trop
de d'agitation il ya beaucoup trop de
communication
le ministre de l'intérieur veut se
pousser du col et il en est réduit à
faire des coups de menton législatif ou
autres quasiment en permanence
moi je pense qu'il faut retrouver une
écriture qui puisse convenir moi je suis
attaché j'entendais ya quelques instants
l'audition de frédéric veaux le dgpn le
patron des policiers
on peut pas laisser nos forces de
l'ordre comme ça en pâture à la vindicte
d'un certain nombre de groupuscules
extrêmement dangereux il faut les
protéger
parce que c'est eux qui nous protège
première chose mais on peut pas non plus
pensé qu' on va réduire les libertés de
la presse
d'ailleurs les policiers c'est pour ça
que monsieur darmanin et est assez
maladroit qu'il est un mauvais
ambassadeur finalement de ses propres
troupes
les policiers ils ne demandent pas de
réduire la liberté des journalistes
ils veulent simplement qu' on puisse
renforcer leurs droits à eux parce que
dans des écoles
il ya des enfants qui ne peuvent même
plus dire la profession de leur papa ou
de leur maman et on vous souvenir de
magnanville ça n'est pas possible que je
pourrais revenir sur tour terminé tout
ça je crois que il faut désormais plus
de sérénité
plutôt que de trop d'agitation et ce que
je demande c'est aussi un peu plus le
résultat est beaucoup moins de
communication à votre avis qu'est ce que
les citoyens retiennent de l'ensemble de
cette séquence vous venez de l'expliquer
c'est quand même très compliqué ce qui
se passait ce que quelle est l'image qui
s'en dégage pour pour le commun des
mortels le couac le cafouillage
cafouillage entre des ministres
cafouillage entre le premier ministre et
ses ministres cafouillage entre le
prison république et son gouvernement
parce que faut pas s'y tromper mêmes
macron était à la manoeuvre depuis le
départ il n'y a pas une réaction n'y a
pas une initiative y compris cette femme
lui commission la commission de
technocrates rendez compte
je parle souvent d'absurde distance est
un de vos collègues allemands qui le
premier il ya quelques jours à utiliser
cette expression pour qualifier la
france
mais là vraiment c'est la pure distance
c'est à dire que on a en france on en
crée
de la technocratie de la bureaucratie et
on invente une commission de
technocrates pour se substituer au
parlement alors que le mal français
c'est la bureaucratie
il ya une crise de légitimité
démocratique
il ya une crise sans doute de la
représentation aussi en france et on
substitue aux mécanismes parlementaires
de la représentation une sorte d'ersatz
de fausse démocratie qui est encore une
fois de la technocratie
donc on aggrave les maux de la france et
il ya une volonté de se passer du sénat
dans cette histoire pour vous mais il ya
une volonté de se passer des corps
intermédiaires depuis longtemps il ya eu
l'épisode des gilet jaune ou emmanuel
macron si j'ose dire a eu chaud donc il
a redécouvert la toux et la puissance
d'occupation du terrain qu'on les maires
il s'est beaucoup appuyé sur le grand
débat notamment sur les élus locaux
mais enlever si j'ose dire cette
actualité
un peu terrible le naturel revient très
vite au galop
qu'est ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui on voit
des ministres par exemple bruno le maire
n'est pas venue du tout du tout pendant
la discussion sur le projet de loi de
finances sur le plan de relance ça n'est
pas rien des dizaines des centaines de
milliards
monsieur vers ans et tout juste venu on
l'a aperçu pour le projet doit de la
sécurité sociale donc le gouvernement
gouverne par décrets c'est à dire qu'il
fait la loi à travers des ordonnances
comme aucun autre gouvernement y compris
au moment de la guerre d'algérie n'a pu
le faire donc
nos institutions sont malmenés et nos
libertés sont rabotés il ya de quoi être
inquiet jusque j'ai entendu hier présent
dans les publics disons aux français je
vais vous punir si jamais vous allez en
suisse on va fermer la frontière mais
dans l'autre sens par l'état des pays
on est dans un des pays qui n'a pas
voulu fermer ses frontières pour se
protéger et là ce serait l'inversé ce
serait pour les français pour rentrer en
france ça on va toujours dire sur ce
sujet mais un mot puisque vous parlez de
président de la république vous vous
devait déjeuner avec lui
à midi en compagnie de gérard larcher et
des autres présidents de groupe il y
avait besoin de renouer les liens entre
le sénat et le président de la
république et qu'est ce que vous allez
lui d'hyères il ya besoin
il faut dire au président de république
qu'à cette tendance de la verticalité
jupitérienne que la démocratie
parlementaire dans une crise c'est pas
un obstacle
c'est pas un handicap c'est un atout
j'avais moi drei tu dis un petit peu ce
qui s'est passé par exemple pour la
première guerre 14-18 où on est un an
situation devrait guère et de où on a
une unité nationale qu'on appelait
l'union saclay sacré jamais le parlement
jamais les commissions n'ont eu une vie
aussi intense il ya eu des commission
denquête l'état-major essayé d'interdire
aux parlementaires
l'accès au front pour se rendre compte
exactement de ce qui se passait il ya
une vie démocratique très intense alors
même que le pays traversait des heures
autrement plus dramatiques que les
autres ce que je veux dire ma prison
république c'est que il faut s'appuyer
sur les élus il faut s'appuyer par
exemple sur le plan de relance les
régions sont écartés du plan de relance
on a nommé vendée compte des sous
préfets à la relance voilà encore une
fois pur dit absurdistan non je pense
que la démocratie parlementaire que le
parlement c'est la vie démocratique et
je crois que on a à chaque fois qu'on
veut se passer du parlement on commet
des erreurs
l'article 20 claque en est une de ces
erreurs mais je crois qu'il y en a
beaucoup d'autres
à chaque fois qu'on veut se passer des
élus locaux on commet aussi des erreurs
tout simplement parce qu'on est dans une
société qui est très complexe et pour
que les décisions soient suivies
d'applications pour qu'elle soit
comprise
elles doivent être prises et elles
doivent être appliquées au plus près du
terrain voilà c'est ce que en france on
a du mal à comprendre
au delà même d'ailleurs des mails macron
on a cette tradition de jacobinisme d'un
centralisme très parisien qui nuit je
crois à l'efficacité de nos politiques
publiques
mais à quel moment et comment vous
expliquez que que l'exécutif ait pu
imaginer qu'ils pourraient procéder à la
faire procéder la réécriture de
l'article 24 en enjambant le l'ailé
parlementaire du cul ça ne provoquera
aucune réaction qui se passerait rien
qu'est ce qui s'est passé enfin la
personne pour leur dire que
pas comme ça que ça marche c'est que ma
jury que ça passerait bien vous avez
raison je pense que ce petit monde vit
dans un vase clos sont des énarques on
est dirigée par un quarteron d'énarques
en france totalement coupés de la
réalité des élus soient des élus
nationaux soient des élus locaux et il
ya une telle certitude d'incarner
comment dirais-je le sens de l'histoire
le camp du bien que peu importe il ya la
verticalité on décide et les autres donc
à appliquer mais c'est stupéfiant c'est
absolument stupéfiant ça témoigne quand
même de cet isolement de cette coupure
est aussi peut-être qu'il n'y a pas
cette pratique parce qu'on critique l
ancien monde mais il n'ya pas être
construction par exemple dans le
parcours des mails macron il n'y a pas
eu la langue construction qui fait
qu'ils seraient passés par exemple par
par exemple un conseil municipal en tout
cas des fonctions locales
et puis ensuite une fonction
parlementaire donc cet apprentissage de
la vie démocratique française de ce
qu'est finalement l'identité
démocratique français a peut-être manqué
un moment ou un autre
alors jean castex n'a pas été député ou
sénateur non plus mais gérald darmanin a
été député du il devrait savoir comment
ça marche quand même oui mais je pense
que le pilotage est essentiellement fait
à l'elysée je pense que c'est ce qui
caractérise la pratique des institutions
il ya une hyperprésidence
on est arrivé et franchement il ya un
problème institutionnel on a déréglé la
vème république avec le quinquennat plus
et peut-être même surtout plus avec
l'inversion du calendrier ou désormais
les députés sont élus dans la foulée de
la présidentielle c'est à dire que les
législatives
c'est le troisième tour des élections
présidentielles donc on a une assemblée
une majorité qui est quand même un petit
peu aux ordres de l'elysée mais quand
même un signe des temps et peut-être
encourageant là il ya peut-être une de
rébellion quand même les députés sont
sorties de leur rôle un peu godillots
pour dire non on existe et de ce point
de vue là je trouve que c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle ils ont eu raison
un mot sur le fond de cet article 24
vous nous dites en gros qu'il est mal
écrit ça veut dire qu'il ya pas de
tentation du vote conforme qui ferait
que cet article est adopté chez vous
pour vous c'est quand même question mais
la tentation de confort mais enfin je
veux dire que tout le monde désormais
reconnaît y compris je crois les
rédacteurs de cet article est très très
mal rédigée par le sénat donc écoutez
moi je suis respectueux de nos
institutions
il ya un rapporteur mars qui devrait si
en commission des lois
je les ai vus tous les deux hier soir
tard et et ils m'ont indiqué qu'elles
étaient leurs pistes mais les pistes
elles sont en cours puisque ils n'ont
pas achevé le travail de préparation le
travail d'auditions parce que quand on
fait une loi c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre ça tombe pas du haut ça peut
pas tomber tout d'un coup quelqu'un qui
dans sa tête pense à une écriture et
qu'il accouche sur le papier non on
auditionnent notamment des
professionnels des professionnels du
droit ce qu'ils sont vraiment confronté
par exemple le dgpn le directeur général
de la police nationale pour voir où est
le problème
et quelles solutions peut apporter une
première action les pistes y aura plus
de référence à la loi de 1881 il m'a dit
c'est c'est stupide c'est idiot
c'est en plus techniquement ça
fonctionnait pas bien je pense que 1 il
faut créer dans le code pénal
puisqu'on a plusieurs dispositifs
aujourd'hui on a quatre ou cinq articles
du code pénal mais qui finalement
peuvent se contredire les uns entre les
autres en tout cas ne sont pas d'une
cohérence parfaite donc je pense que
c'est le code pénal
je pense qu'il faut plutôt viser la
viralité c'est à dire la communication
par internet
voilà et après il faut qu'on voie
comment on traite ces deux articles
l'article 24 dans un texte
et puis le fameux article 25 dans un
autre texte mais je fais confiance à la
commission des lois
croyez moi qui est d'une très très haute
technicité qui est très professionnel
dans son approche je pense que j'espère
que dans les prochaines semaines on aura
une réécriture une rédaction nouvelle
escale tellement nouvel ace qui est pas
le risque que pour apaiser les choses au
gouvernement aubeterre
non pas l'article 24 qui peut pas
l'enterrer tout seul qu'il en perd
complètement la proposition de loi ça
vous seriez favorable ce type de
scénario ou pas non la proposition de
loi il ya du bon dans cette dans cette
loi sur la sécurité globale c'est une
petite loi pour l'instant parce que il
n'a été voté que par l'une des deux
assemblées
donc je redis que nous sommes dans un
système parlementaire bicamérale il ya
deux champs mais pour faire la loi
il faut passer dans les deux champs de
sécurité par exemple le rôle des polices
municipales on l'a vu à nice c'est parce
que la police municipale était bien
équipée qu'on a réussi à neutraliser le
terrorisme que les polices municipales
vont prendre à l'avenir un rôle de plus
en plus décisif pour assurer la
protection de nos concitoyens donc je ne
vois pas en quoi une une maladresse
d'écriture entacherait l'ensemble d'un
texte je vous rappelle aussi qu'il ya le
texte sur le séparatiste sur le
renforcement des principes républicains
qui vient en conseil des ministres
mercredi prochain
donc il y aura à nouveau un débat
puisque c'est l'article 25
un texte qui vise à créer un délit de
mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
notamment par les mêmes procédés ou les
mêmes exactions
donc de toute façon le gouvernement
n'échappera pas à ce débat et compter
sur le sénat pour remettre sur la table
précisément et le des rédactions
séparatiste dont on connaît les grandes
lignes vous parler de cet article 25
mais on en connaît d'autres est ce qu a
priori vous êtes plutôt favorable à haut
contenu de ce texte dans mes jeux
j'étais un de ceux et je suis un des
parlementaires qui porte ce combat je
crois très fortement sur la laïcité et
aussi pour combattre le terrorisme
islamiste
j'ai toujours regretté que ml macron
soit d'une forme d'ambiguïté il aura
fallu la dernière année parce que le
fameux texte contre l'islamisme va
commencer à s'appliquer à la dernière
année de son quinquennat donc il lui
aura fallu quatre années de réflexion
alors que les attentats c'est depuis
2012 vous rendez compte depuis huit ans
pour envisager un texte donc qu' un
texte et c'est très bien et c'est le bon
texte ça va assez loin pour vous non non
parce que si vous posez cette question
je pense que il ne va ni au bout des
choses ni au fond des choses il ne va
pas au bout des choses je vais vous
donner un seul exemple
par exemple le voile nous avions voté
ici l'interdiction des signes
ostentatoires donc du voile pour les
sorties scolaires dans le temps scolaire
parce que c'est interdit à l'école
pendant le temps scolaire donc les
sorties scolaires c'est l'école hors les
murs donc ce doit être les mêmes règles
et on voit bien que l'islamisme et 7 de
marquer le territoire
c'est un double séparatisme ils essaient
d'isoler en marquant notamment les
femmes
la communauté musulmane du reste de la
communauté nationale et en france avec
la citoyenneté la laïcité nous ne
reconnaissons qu'une seule communauté
c'est la communauté des citoyens et je
disais double séparatistes parce qu'il
ya aussi un marquage de la femme qui
pour eux et d'un rang inférieur aux
sommes tous à hoerdt aux nouvelles
heures donc je pense que moi je suis
pour qu'on aille plus loin je pense
qu'il faut aussi sanctionner les
récidives pour la burqa
voilà y compris en arrêtant les aides
sociales pour celle qui récidive bien
sûr je suis pour l'interdiction du voile
dans l'université donc on ne va pas au
bout des choses mais on ne va pas non
plus au fond des choses pourquoi parce
qu'il ya un lien kemmel macro lui même a
dû reconnaître entre le désordre
migratoires et la question du terrorisme
plusieurs d'ailleurs attentats ont été
commis par des immigrés soit qui était
sur le territoire illégalement soit qui
était sur le territoire de façon légale
donc on n'y coupera pas on n'y coupera
pas et pour l'instant il n'y a rien il
ya juste un débat vous rendez compte il
n'y a qu'un débat alors qu'en france il
faut que les français le sachent
il ya ce désordre migratoires et tous
les ans ont franchi de nouveaux records
l'an dernier c'était 275 mille entrées
pour des séjours et des titres de séjour
qu'on a délivré il ya eu 135 mille
demandes de droit d'asile
la france est désormais le premier pays
européen pour ceux qui sont déboutés du
droit d'asile viennent chez nous parce
que on est plus laxistes donc on a un
problème
un sur le droit d'asile qu'il faut
réformer 2 sur le regroupement familial
qu'il faut réformer comme l'a fait la
suède comme l'a fait même où l'allemagne
et 3 l'accès aux soins oulaye a beau
ou de laxisme quand j'entends le
président république dira faut réformer
schengen très bien mais ce dont je vous
parle ne dépendent pas de l'europe
dépend des décisions françaises
que fait-on et on ne réglera pas le
problème du terrorisme islamisme si on
n'a pas un combat global je pense que ce
combat c'est le combat d'une génération
je pense qu'une seule loi d'ailleurs ne
peut pas le traiter je pense que il faut
le traiter à la racine
je pense qu'il faut le traiter en
mettant fin au désordre migratoire je
pense qu'il faut le traiter dans un
combat qui est aussi un combat
idéologique bien sûr par exemple les
guerre mémorielle
si vous enclenchez cette espèce de
concurrence mémorielle si vous dites que
perpétuellement décidément la france ne
peut pas être aimable puisque la france
elle est l'éternel coupable comment
voulez vous si vous débiner la france
comme l'a dit un jour jean pierre
chevènement comment voulez-vous agrégé à
notre destin collectif des jeunes
générations qui sont sur le chemin du
séparatisme
il faut rendre la france un peu aimable
pour que ces générations puisse l'aimer
et nous souvent notre réflexe notre
sport national
c'est de la rabaisser vous n'avez pas le
sentiment qu emmanuel macron a évolué
ces derniers temps sur toutes ces
questions il évolue en permanence
il évolue en permanence ils changent en
permanence cette extraordinaire où c'est
pas mon style virevoltent
il virevolte et vous pourrez à chaque
déclaration trouver l'un vers de ce
qu'il a pu faire il ya ya pu dire il ya
il ya un an
il ya deux choses qui le caractérise
cesser ces changements de pied permanent
et c'est cette différence abyssale entre
des discours où on peut tout à fait se
retrouver parce que les constats sont
souvent justes et ensuite les actes il
ya vraiment un abîme entre les deux
c'est pour comprendre emmanuel macron je
crois que il faut bien comprendre c'est
ces deux aspects qui forment la matrice
de sa personnalité politique
un mot sur la crise sanitaire et la
crise économique un et cette déclaration
bruno le maire s'était hier soir sur lci
qui dit qui met la pression il met la
pression sur les assureurs et leur dit
que s'il n'y a pas de gel de primes pour
les cafés pour les restaurants pour
l'est pour l'hôtellerie et bien le
gouvernement soutiendra l'amendement qui
a été voté par le sénat dans
budget cet amendement il instaure un
prélèvement de 1,2 milliard sur les
assureurs amendements qu'il qualifie de
très brutal d'ailleurs qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
non mais sur le fond je suis d'accord
voyez que le sénat est utile puisque on
a voté un amendement qui vise à vis des
assurances un avertissement en dix ans
très bien vous ne bougez pas alors on
vous taxera moi j'aime pas les taxes
pourquoi est ce qu'on taxe là parce que
on a le sentiment que les assurances se
sont défaussés alors qu' il y avait des
assurances perte d'exploitation elles
ont trouvé des arguties
d'ailleurs certaines ont été condamnés
par le tribunal
elles vont devoir rembourser mais vont
devoir payer mes seins elle se sont
défaussés 2 il ya eu moins de
sinistralité
elles ont finalement pendant cette
période parfois eu moins de
remboursements à payer que dans les
périodes normales est long et difficile
et donc d'une rente de situation donc la
taxation d'une grande de situation quand
un pays souffre alors que une activité
se porte bien et prospère sur cette
souffrance voilà il ya une justification
donc voila moi je pense qu'il ya un bras
de fer
moi je suis très heureux que le sénat
puisse fournir aux ministres de
l'économie et des finances
un bon argument pour se faire comprendre
je crois que de ce point de vue là la
carotte et le bâton de temps en temps ça
peut servir sur la crise sanitaire
elle-même comment est ce que vous voyez
la campagne de vaccination qui s'annonce
est ce que vous pensez que c'est un
outil qui peut être efficaces pour
surmonter la crise et est-ce qu'on va
être en capacité de l'utiliser ou de
lait de le développer dans de bonnes
conditions en france messieurs je crois
que le premier antidote puisqu'on parle
de vaccins contre le virus contre
l'épidémie c'est la confiance la
confiance qui a été terriblement 10 mai
abîmée par la sphère des masques à faire
des tests ensuite pendant déconfinement
abîmés par des décisions parfois
stupides on parlait de la jauge de 30
personnes dans les lieux de culte bon il
ya une condamnation
cette confiance elle est écornée en
france et cette confiance quand on parle
de vaccins elle est encore plus
affaiblie puisqu'on est de tous les pays
d'europe
le pays qui a le moins confiance alors
qu'on est le plus dense heures alors que
nous sommes le pays pasteur terrible
paradoxe
vous avez raison de souligner ce que je
veux dire moi c'est qu'il faudra se
faire vacciner
que on a oublié mais la variole a tué
300 millions de personnes avant que le
vaccin soit généralisé que la
tuberculose faisait des millions de
morts tous les ans et ça ce sont les
vaccins qui ont éradiqué ces mots il
faudra se faire vacciner vous soyez vous
seriez partisans d'une vaccination
obligatoire capital non non je pense que
je le non je ne suis pas partisan et je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi je pense
que ça poserait beaucoup plus de
problèmes que ça ne résoudrait de
question dans la mesure où comment faire
appliquer cette obligation quand vous
créez une obligation
alors quelle sanction alors le meilleur
moyen de convaincre vous allez dans la
rue essayez de demander aux gens une
attestation de vaccination vous les
embarquer pour être vaccinés au premier
poste chez un maître non c'est papy
comment convaincre les français du coup
de se faire vacciner
d'abord peut-être par leur civisme
parce que j'ai observés il ya une
tendance de l'état de dire que de
morigéner les français moi je trouve que
très franchement ils ont été plutôt
assez civique
bon il faut dire aux français ce qu'est
un vaccin
il faut peut-être leur dire aussi que le
propre d'un vaccin la vertu d'un vaccin
c'est pas tellement de se protéger soi
même et c'est de protéger les autres et
c'est le problème dans cette société
contemporaine terriblement
individualiste en oublie la dimension
collective
le vaccin c'est le matelas vaccinale
c'est le fait qu'on obtienne un moment
donné une sorte d'immunité collective
mais pour ça il faut qu'une part
significative de la population accepte
de se faire vacciner
donc moi je pense que pas d'obligation
je pense qu'il faut commencer bien sûr
par les plus fragiles et il faut surtout
pas dire que ils serviront de cobayes
certainement pas je prends me faire
vacciner dans les tous premiers sait
s'il faut montrer le chemin mais je
crois au vaccin je crois en la science
je pense que on n'éradiquera j'écoutais
ce matin un reportage sur l'éco vie de
long vous avez des gens plutôt jeunes
d'ailleurs qu'ils ont été touchés qui
ont été très peu touchés qui ne sont pas
allés à l'hôpital et qui des mois
faisait mois après
importantes ont des effets mais terrible
donc ce virus est une saloperie donc les
moyens que nous offre la science sont
bons pour qu'on puisse se laisser saisir
donc je pense qu'il faut aussi demandé à
ceux qui soignent les personnes âgées à
tout le personnel soignant de se faire
vacciner
ça me paraît extrêmement important la
haute autorité de santé a décliné un
certain nombre de priorités avec cinq
étapes
ça peut être discutée mais en tout cas
pour le pour éviter la troisième vague
la première chose à faire c'est de se
vacciner le plus massivement possible et
une dernière question bruno retailleau
ne pouvez pas vous laisser partir sans
un mot sur le vendée globe et stéphane
oui on imagine que vous avez suivi
l'incroyable sauvetage de kevin
escoffier par par jean le cam et vous
suiviez d'une manière générale avec
beaucoup d'attention cette course est ce
que comment comment est ce que laisse
les choses cet épisode a résonné pour
pour le vendre et que vous êtes cette
année a coûté je suis d'angers organisé
j'étais président de la société que
d'économistes qui comment dirais-je qui
organise cette cette course m'a coûté le
vendée globe c'est ça c'est pas une
course
c'est d'abord une aventure une aventure
humaine extraordinaire il ya quelques
mois on s'est beaucoup interrogé pour
savoir si on autoriserait le départ de
la course et on s'est dit ça sera sans
doute dans des conditions diminué par
rapport à l'habitude mais faut que cette
course et part parce que ce sera un
déconfinement extraordinaire pour tous
les français et pour les centaines de
millions de spectateurs qui suivent qui
embarquent à bord grâce aux petits
caméra d'ailleurs qui sont embarqués sur
les sur les bateaux et je pense qu'on a
bien fait parce que tous ces skippers
ont emporté avec une part de notre
liberté dans leurs voiles une part de
nos rêves et moi je me souviens de cette
et bertrand de broc qui s'était recousu
la langue
je me souviens du sauvetage de raphaël
dinelli et là on a une histoire
extraordinaire puisque jean le cam avait
été sauvée par un ancien skipper d'un
bateau prb vincent riou ya onze ans et
là c'est jean le cam qui sauve le
nouveau skipper kevin du bateau prb
permettent une grande entreprise je
salue d'ailleurs jean jacques laurent
qui est un sponsor depuis le départ
qui est une entreprise qui dirige une
entreprise familiale extraordinaire mais
vraiment le vendée globe c'est ça c'est
une aventure humaine où les gens vont
puiser au fond d'eux-mêmes pour rien du
tout ça gagne pas ce que gagne un type
qui joue dans des par exemple au
football ou ailleurs ils le font ils
mettent leur vie en danger
ils mettent leur vie en danger mais ils
leur font pour le fonds pour la jeunesse
le vendée globe c'est la dernière grande
aventure humaine
qu'ils soient donnés je pense à des
hommes de vivre des hommes et des femmes
d'ailleurs les des femmes rien de bien
sûr hier donc c'est une nouvelle page
qu'on a inscrit qu ils ont écrit tous
les deux mais surtout le roi jean jean
le cam yes we can cessons c'était ça son
slogan yes we came
il a écrit cette page donc elle viendra
donc ajouter à toutes les autres pages
qui font la légende de grandes sources
bien sûr à suivre les aventures de ces
skippers merci beaucoup merci bruno
retailleau d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin merci stéphane on regarde la une
de ouest france consacré aux produits
pour les fêtes merci d'avoir été avec
nos stéphane merci messieurs
[Musique]